junge junge das gibt's doch nicht mal
eindeutig wir haben locker schon zehn
minuten aufgenommen und echter immer
noch immer noch 83 redet wieder muss los
[Musik]
willkommen zu einem neuen videospiel
hier mit luca mit dem finnen all den
luca dran hängt und wir machen heute ein
video über die verrücktesten weichenried
kassenseite gefunden und wie schon heute
die verrücktesten weichen auf dieser
seite an reagieren oft fangen wir an
einer bestbewerteten geschichten aller
zeiten an einem freitagabend war mir
ziemlich langweilig und es war nichts
los um zwei uhr morgens mit erste mal
draußen spazieren gegangen und einem
haus vorbeigelaufen buchen eine
hauptstadt fahren jacke klingelten wurde
von zwei drucke menschen dämpfer ich
ging einfach hinein feierte mit fremden
menschen denen vor lauter alkohol gleich
aufgefallen war dass ein fremder mit
verdi habe jedenfalls ordentlich
getrunken und bin dann im badezimmer
aufgewacht alle haben noch geschlafen
und ich habe mir in dieser fremden küche
einfach frühstück gemacht die zeitung
gelesen habe ohne meinen teller
abzuwaschen das haus verlassen diese
sache ist eins zu eins so an karneval
passiert das war hier ja ich war in
kanada unterwegs und kommen sie her und
wer unten vor lucas bögl stehen einfach
so 30 menschen von denen ich niemanden
kenne diese hoch
johann grafl 30 menschen gefolgt sie
kannte dich kontinente beschränkt leute
wir haben 13 uhr probieren sie es
einfach aus dem 300 500 so die sängerin
dabei warte ich habe mega teams gesehen
dass gefährlich ja weiß was passieren
kann
es kann sein dass du einfach ein video
faken muss weil sonst passiert in bayern
morgens und schwächer werden und respekt
schauspieler und kann seine stars
kleber vielleicht mal drehen vielleicht
klappt es
[Musik]
meine uhr fackeln drei wochen schneller
ich finde einfach gewissenlosen hat sich
das video gesehen dass niemals um drei
uhr nachts müssen drei nachwuchs muss
zwar schlecht schauspieler und sonst hab
ich hasse es wenn ich meine hose
ausziehen
ich hatte meine hose aus dir die
enttäuschung in den gesichtern der
frauen zu sehen ich möchte dass sie sich
fürchten nicht sicherstellen da vorgeht
so mehrere hause möchte seinen stücken
zeigen und dann seine hose außen sie
morgen mein gott
kannst du das nachvollziehen dass man
will das mädel sich vor dem eigenen
geschlecht fürchten
aber es ist auch nicht schön natürlich
auch luca die nächste heißt
zwillingsbrüder lichkeiten ein eineiiger
zwillingsbruder und ich [ __ ] seit zwei
wochen
dort ist in meinem jungen zu ersetzen
das gibt's doch nicht machen leute wir
haben locker 15 minuten aufgenommen und
es war immer noch immer 83 drehten fit
muss los um 3 uhr